haha go and read my name she's very fat
welcome back to do three we're gonna
start right away in another day I hate
starting videos like this but all right
I'm gonna plug in gotta cut again I
already said that are [ __ ] everywhere
alright come on ah stop stop stop by a
bit rope
no stop not today not today not today
sayonara [ __ ] ass oh [ __ ] they can fly
I forgot that
alright alright ah throw away
I hate this game son of a barrel fine
fine
I don't even care okay let's go I forgot
a thing in the last episode I don't know
don't kill me don't kill me bad things
oh I got your son oh if it bleeds you
can raise it
I want to rape you what Pam stop stop
stop stop that huh
calm down come back calm down
everything's gonna be fine everything's
fine like jump oh no no more no more no
more I think that come here come here
a little the middle plants right Jen
you're never but if you learn if it was
in your face that is eyeshadow got a
real eye ah this is bad this is bad bad
bad bad bad bad
no it's good again again zip again don't
why I said this but that's really good
all right no more demon heads
[ __ ] open [ __ ] alright let's try to deal
over them
[ __ ] I hate the Internet I gotta aim for
the head got a day
what is this flange Minute Trainer I
don't even know what that is
well this [ __ ] I looked hi is this blind
Metatrader holy [ __ ] that is a lot of
debris what happened in here Marta yeah
go and don't make me shoot aah
don't slap me what how would I leave you
come brother holy [ __ ] you sucker it's
so much better at this game I'm chucking
over your cut
oh you trip thing and then Kim great
alright some ammo would be [ __ ]
fantastic
oh no shoot the mouse shoot the bear
sure yeah that's how I roll
you can't even kick to me you suck so
much
you don't even know what you okay I [ __ ]
my Romanian no no no I'm fine
this game is way too difficult at the
moment amber would have helped a little
bit I'm not gonna lie
son of a barrel dad you can't you don't
look at me like that
don't do it it's not that easy all right
but da da da all right
don't don't give me that look I'm trying
here let's try our time
bring it all right it's not in here
quick SEC shut up lady
so what it's like oh oh oh yes baby yes
baby sex addicted about me and you do
two kind of out [ __ ] up [ __ ] American
bath
[ __ ] in Wow don't suck my penis oh is
that a girl no it's not with that sound
all you have to offer okay that is not
good to me
can I hear one behind me to shut oh I
can dear friend I brought you clothes oh
you were close with him oh you're angry
Oh guess what I don't care I don't even
care I'm an IKEA top 9 I am 9 hell oh
you look good look at someone who care
I don't even care no bad spider but
spider now not today hey to help Mom
we're down down ok no one else are you
getting me no no now wait a jumper games
ridiculous what the [ __ ]
alright I got it now just don't jump in
the shower
I mean that later whatever it's called
don't jump don't jump in it oh [ __ ] that
does 855 like more than your mama Oh
come on elevator faster faster
I'm have yet why do you shoot I mean -
sure that all right go have anything
nope I got [ __ ] rap Nate I have [ __ ]
AIDS
Nate's are so useful when you have one
health up take it no no no no oh I got
one alright just don't eat me
oh this is gonna be difficult I better
put on my tryout face with this one all
right I got Nate's so it's fine
technically all right I just got to use
my name's why did I say when I was dying
but if I throw a nade out well they'd
explode in the air and think we know
that beyond acceptable that is not good
[Music]
I need something else ended all right
throw that thing
it-it-it
hey that
hey that eat it eat it eat it you eat it
now in my face please don't leave my
face please I need my face please in it
oh he's scared of elevators don't finish
I'll hate it don't jump down step it
[ __ ]
oh wait I can just shoot it right
there's so many all right don't worry
about pigs in it so much fireball it's
not gonna kill me it's one more in here
huh
not today sir nah just a this is not
your time to shine
that's not your time to show oh yes oh
it's armor charge they don't help me I
still have one else ha ha ha
don't ya what are you what are you xx
huh where are you from huh Indonesia
no no bad but should the better yeah
duck your [ __ ] like a duck your mamma's
present because why I don't know why you
just don't like our Thursday okay huh
don't be offended no no no bat bat shoot
the man shoot back
yes got your back down so good I was no
good
give me a half Fang get me a house back
please get this man a half pack
I need a half this is nice
you got a spawn kill now is that your
deal it's fine with me spy on me
think I care I invented spun Kenny don't
spawn kill me bamm-bamm fine fine fine
fine thanks we got this look at these
strafing skills look at this
and then when I was gonna [ __ ] with me
please give me house no you're not a
have station ah [ __ ]
Oh where'd I get help from
I don't even care huh come to Papa a
little bit Allah I was good
Oh
Oh No what are they doing I don't even
care about the reactor do you see the
card no sir there's no cars in fact the
communication facility I want oh there
it is how can he not see the card a
counselor
oh I want that card - these tell me I
can drive that car whoa I'm sniffing on
them that hurt why does that I have a
pass my gun I don't even care I don't
get come on [ __ ] come at me brush
come at me bring me your wife bitch-ass
as that's all you got that's just all
you got I got a [ __ ] laser gun this
all you got
sons of [ __ ] they don't even know
what they're talking about it
holy [ __ ] there's an amazing all right
so now we go back I doesn't make any
sense
Oh maybe to go back to the car I guess I
don't know
let's see sir yeah stay down and stay
down
let's go up let's go let's go I'm ready
don't tell me we got a shift people in
here I don't like it's on fire aah chefs
it's not good not shooting it doesn't
have Sunday Oh Pamela every way
the hell I don't know and tell me I mean
can't have a plus him again I didn't
pass my gun go why did it pass my going
near my tip as my gun gun why didn't you
go [ __ ] it out okay
I get the feeling I'm not supposed to go
back yep maybe we are done never [ __ ]
[ __ ] I hate you no one likes you don't
even do things you don't got enough
friends
oh I feel so bad for you that's fine bye
ah [ __ ]
don't all right
Thanks
no one likes
oh okay cool now we can go in here old
you you you you you you you you little
rascals what are you anyway
huh [ __ ] [ __ ] ah PDA is not the time for
today where's my plasma now you are come
back here well nevermind that's how I
roll that's how I get on the ladies okay
yeah
stop stop stop all of you alright what
do I do it you're not supposed to be
here spider there anyone else thanks for
lining up for me you do realize I have a
plasma gun right
yuria I rape your ass what was that
Wow [ __ ] sons a barrel
what do you want hahaha eyes back to the
brother buddy
alright I get it I get it I get what I
gotta do
okay that was not what I was gonna get
fine fine
I have to end this episode here anyway
chef's there's a lot action in these
episodes but I can't write
it's geico birthday and I'll see you
next episode over I make Jasper I don't
you [ __ ] hat on side of a [ __ ] I'll
keep going then I did it again
whoo [ __ ] stops [ __ ] all right